WITH -- IT'S 5:00 IN
NEW YORK CITY.
SUBSTANCE ABUSE IS ON THE TRUMP
ADVISOR.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ADDRESSED IT
EARLIER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE ARE GOING TO THE LETTER SOON.
>> MORNEAU FROM CHIEF
INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE.
HI, KATHERINE.
>> THANKS, KIMBERLY.
THE
THE LONG-STANDING CONGRESSIONAL
RULES, THE PRESIDENT HAS FIVE
DAYS TO VOICE OBJECTIONS ABOUT
THE MEMO WHICH TECHNICALLY
BRINGS US TODAY OR MONDAY
COUNTING BUSINESS DATES.
THAT MEANS THERE'S A HANDFUL OF
OPTIONS FOR THE PRESIDENT.
HE CAN DECLASSIFY THE MEMO AS
IS, DECLASSIFY THE MEMO WITH
LIMITED REACTIONS, OR REDRAFT
THE MEMO BEFORE THE
PRESIDENT WILL CONSIDER IT
AGAIN.
THEY HAVE ASKED ALL PARTIES
INCLUDING THE FBI AND JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO REVIEW THE MEMO
AND MAKE THE RECOMMENDATIONS
ABOUT WHAT NEEDS TO BE REDACTED
OR BLACKED OUT.
THE VERSION DRAFTED BY THE
RANKING DEMOCRAT ON THE
COMMITTEE, ADAM SCHIFF, IS TWICE
THAT LONG AS 15 PAGES COMPARED
DIVE WITH THE SOURCES AND
METHODS, WE ARE TOLD THAT
REDACTION IS LIKELY.
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, THE FORMER
BRITISH SPY WHO RESEARCH THE
DOSSIER HAD A TRACK RECORD WITH
INVESTIGATORS OR CREDIT ABILITY.
REPUBLICANS COUNTER THAT THE FBI
CUT TIES WITH STEELE BECAUSE HE
LIED ABOUT THEM.
BUT THIS INFORMATION WAS NEVER
SHARED WITH THAT NATIONAL
SECURITY COURT THAT GRANTED
THERE WAS FISA LAWRENCE FOR
CARTER PAGE.
KIMBERLY?
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
UPDATE.
A DEVELOPING STORY P AND WE ARE
WAITING FOR THE COUNTER MEMO,
GREG WITH YOU SITTING THERE WITH
ANTICIPATION --
>> DON'T YOU SAY, I'M GLAD TO
SEE YOU.
IT'S BEEN THREE DAYS?
>> EXACTLY.
HOW WE'VE MISSED YOU SO.
>> YES.
ALL RIGHT.
>> SO LITTLE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I'M OUT OF HERE.
IT'S FRIDAY.
I'M GOING TO WALK INTO A DOOR.
>> DON'T LET THAT DOOR HIT YOU
ON THE WAY OUT.
>> THEY WILL WREAK RELEASE THE
DEMOCRATIC MEMO, THE REPUBLICANS
SHOULD RELEASE A COUNTER
RESPONSE.
THERE DEMOCRAT SHOULD DO IF YOU
KEEP DOING THIS -- IT'S LIKE A
PART OF
PARTISAN VERSION OF ROCK, PAPER,
SCISSORS.
JUST KEEP GOING FOREVER AND EVER
AND EVER.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
THIS IS NOW A POLITICAL HE SHED
SEE SHE
HE SAID, SHE SAID.
REPUBLICAN KIND, YOU CANNOT
DISMISS DEMOCRATIC RUSSIAN
COLLUSION, YOU'VE GOT A RUSSIAN
SPY DELIVERING UNSOURCED
INFORMATION TO THE GOVERNMENT
IF THAT'S NOT COLLUSION, I AM
FOOT FIVE.
I SUGGEST DECLARE OUR RUSSIAN
COLLUSION NARRATIVE CANCELS OUT
YOUR RUSSIAN COLLUSION
NARRATIVE.
>> DO THEY HAVE THAT?
>> THEY DO.
>> I WILL SEE YOU AFTER THE
SHOW.
>> LET ME SHARE MY THEORY.
RELEASE THE DAMN MEMO, GET IT
OUT THERE.
IT'S GOING TO BE OUT THERE
ANYWAY.
LET'S STOP THIS CONVERSATION.
SO BORING, SO TEDIOUS.
HERE'S MY THEORY.
SO HERE IS STEELE.
WE KNOW THAT STEELE WAS WORKING
TOWARD THE HILLARY CLINTON
CAMPAIGN.
HERE IS STEELE.
STEELE PRODUCES THE DOSSIER, THE
DOSSIER LEADS IN PART TO THE
FISA WARRANT, INVOCATION CARTER
PAGE AND ARE
OTHERS.
WHAT IF, STEELE, RATHER THAN
GENERATING ALL THIS INFORMATION,
IS BEING FED INFORMATION BY THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN -- YOU KNOW,
THIS IS A VERY CONNECTED GROUP
IF YOU HAVE THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN
PRODUCES THE DOSSIER THAT
PRODUCES THE FISA WARRANT?
YOU HAVE THE INVOCATION HERE?
YOU HAVE CLINTON AND THE
CAMPAIGN.
>> SPENT 24 IS SOMEWHERE
COLD HERE SOMEPLACE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE FBI KNOWS.
WHAT I'M IMPLYING HERE, WHEN THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN SEEKS TO FIND
PRODUCING THE DOSSIER.
SO FAR, POLITICS.
BUT THEN RESULTING IN A FISA
WARRANT?
I THINK THIS IS A POSSIBILITY.
>> WHAT YOU ARE SAYING, THE REAL
STORY, SO MUCH OF THE MEDIA AND
REPUBLICANS FOCUSING ON THE FISA
WARRANT, YOU'RE SAYING THAT THE
REAL STORY IS HRC.
I WILL SAY THIS.
I LIVE WITH SOMEONE WHO HAS SEEN
THE DEMOCRAT MEMO.
I LOOK AT ALL THE REPORTS.
THE REPORTS ARE SAYING THAT THE
MEMO FROM THE DEMOCRATS IS NOT
NECESSARILY DISCOUNTING OR
UNDERMINING ANY OF THE THINGS
THAT WERE IN THE REPUBLICAN
MEMO.
IN MY OPINION, IT'S JUST ABOUT
-- LIKE YOU SAY, YOU PUT ONE
OUT, WE'LL PUT ONE OUT.
WE'LL START TO MUDDY THE WATERS,
WE'LL START TO CONFUSE PEOPLE.
WE WILL PUT PURPOSELY, AS TREY
GOWDY SAID, WILL PUT CLASSIFIED
HAS TO REDACT IT. >
HAS TO REDACT IT.              C
HAS TO REDACT IT.              T
HAS TO REDACT IT.              E
HAS TO REDACT IT.              I
HAS TO REDACT IT.              H
HAS TO REDACT IT.              R
HAS TO REDACT IT.              I
HAS TO REDACT IT.              G
HAS TO REDACT IT.              E
HAS TO REDACT IT.              N
SAID, THE DEMOCRATIC MEMO HAS A
DEEP DIVE INTO SOURCES AND
METHODS.
SO THE DEMOCRATS HOWL BECAUSE
THE REPUBLICAN MEMO WAS GOING TO
THEY INTENTIONALLY PUT SOURCES
AND METHODS IN, WHICH WE KNOW
ARE THE MOST VULNERABLE AND
DANGEROUS PART OF ANYTHING
THAT'S CLASSIFIED BECAUSE IT
UNDERMINES OUR ABILITY TO GET
THAT INTELLIGENCE, THEN TRUMP
HAS TO REDACT TO ACTUALLY BE
RESPONSIBLE, ALL THE WHILE WHILE
MUDDY THE WATERS, MAKE IT LOOK
LIKE HE SAID, SHE SAID.
WHY DON'T THE DEMOCRATS CARE
ABOUT THE OTHER SIDE OF THIS
GOING FLEX MIKE WHY DON'T THE
WHY DON'T THEY CARE ABOUT THE
OBVIOUS COLLUSION OF --
>> THE KEY IS THAT MUELLER SEEMS
TO BE CONCENTRATING ON
EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENS AFTER
THE PURPORTED COLLUSION.
LYING, OBSTRUCTION OF --
EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENED SINCE
THE ALLEGED COLLUSION, BECAUSE
HE HAD NOTHING ON COLLUSION OR
WE WOULD'VE HEARD ABOUT THAT A
YEAR INTO THIS.
I THINK THAT AT SOME POINT,
IT'S UNFAIR FOR THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES TO LIVE WITH
THIS CLOUD AND SHADOW GOVERNMENT
THIS CLOUD AND SHADOW GOVERNMEN
GOVERNMENT.
>> DO IT YOURSELF!
>> I THINK YOU BETTER EXPLAIN
WHO YOU'RE SLEEPING WITH.
>> NOT ADAM SCHIFF.
MUCH CUTER.
>> NOW THE TOP DEMOCRAT IN
CHARGE OF THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION HAS BEEN REVEALED
AS MARK WARNER MENTIONING      I
AS MARK WARNER MENTIONING      G
AS MARK WARNER MENTIONING      A
RUSSIAN OLIGARCH.
REACTING TO THE NEWS SAYING,
WARNER DID NOT WANT A PAPER
TRAIL ON A PRIVATE MEETING IN
LONDON.
HE REQUESTED
STEELE -- ALL TIED TO CROOKED
HILLARY.
SOME OF WARNER'S COLLEAGUES ARE
SENATOR FULLY DISCLOSED WITH THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY, AND ZERO
IMPACT ON THE PANEL WORD.
WHAT DID I MAKE OF THIS?
>> THEY SAY THE TEXT LOOKS BAD
WHEN THEY ARE OUT OF CONTEXT.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT AND PUTTING
IT IN CONTEXT, IT'S NO LONGER
NEWS.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
WITH EVERYTHING THESE DAYS.
THAT MAYBE IT'S NOTHING.
BUT HE DIDN'T BRING A REPUBLICAN
WITH HIM WHEN HE WENT AND
INVESTIGATED THIS.
HE SAID, I'M DOING THIS FOR THE
GOOD OF THE COUNTRY, BUT HE DID
IT PRIVATELY ON HIS OWN.
THE FACT IS PEOPLE DIDN'T KNOW
ABOUT THIS.
IT GOES BACK TO THIS TRIBAL TO
TRIBAL THING NOW WITH THESE
PARTIES.
IF YOU SAY THIS TEXT IS WORSE
THAN WATERGATE, THERE IS A GUY
JUST LIKE YOU SAYING THAT THE
TRUMP RUSSIAN COLLUSION THING IS
WORSE THAN WATERGATE.
THESE ARE MIRROR IMAGES.
IF YOU CLEAR OUT ALL THIS TRIBAL
PARTISANSHIP, IT WILL BECOME
MUCH CLEARER AND WE CAN LAUGH
ABOUT IT.
>> IT STILL THINKS, THOUGH.
THIS IS MARCH 2017 WHEN THE
OUTREACH OCCURS.
DIRECTLY FROM THE RANKING MEMBER
OF THE SENATE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTED TO A RUSSIAN LOBBYIST
WITH CONNECTIONS TO CHRISTOPHER
STEELE.
HE DOESN'T NOTIFY THE COMMITTEE
UNTIL SIX MONTHS LATER WHEN HE
REALIZED, THIS WILL LOOK STINKY
IF IT EVER COMES OUT.
YET, THE FELLOW MEMBERS OF HIS
COMMITTEE -- I DON'T KNOW, A LOT
OF BACKSLAPPING LOOKING OUT FOR
EACH OTHER, WILLING TO APOLOGIZE
FOR IT.
THE REALITY IS HE WENT SOLO.
HE WANTED TO GO SOLO OFF THE
GRID, NO PAPER TRAIL, STRAIGHT
TO CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
SHOWS HOW MUCH THIS UNVERIFIED
DIRTY DOSSIER IS THE CENTER OF
EVERYTHING USED TO JUSTIFY
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, BRITISH SPY,
IS IT NOT A FACT THAT
CHRISTOPHER STEELE HAS AN
OBSESSIVE HATRED FOR
DONALD TRUMP?
IS IT NOT A FACT ON THE RECORD
THAT CHRISTOPHER STEELE IS ON
THE RECORD DOING EVERYTHING HE
CAN DO TO OBSTRUCT THE ELECTION
OF DONALD TRUMP AND TO TAKE FROM
DOWN?
I THINK HIS PERSONAL MOTIVATION
AT SOME POINT DEMAND SCRUTINY.
HE HAS REFUSED TO TESTIFY, AS
FAR AS I KNOW, TO THE CONGERS
MEN OF THE UNITED        UNITEDS
MEN OF THE UNITED        UNITED.
>> SO DON'T MARK WARNER.
YOU MAKE SUCH A GREAT POINT.
MARK WARNER WAS DOING THIS
MONTHS AND MONTHS BEFORE THAT
AND NEVER TOLD ANYBODY.
YOU HAVE TO WONDER, WHY DOES HE
GO ROGUE?
IF YOU UNDERSTAND HOW KUHN'S
WORK, THEY HAVE A TON OF
STAFFERS.
HE WOULD NEVER COORDINATE YOUR
STAFFERS DO IT.
YOU WOULD INVOLVE THE STAFFERS
OF MARCO RUBIO, WHOEVER ELSE.
AS HE SAID IN THE TEXT MESSAGES,
NO PAPER TRAIL.
STINKS TO HIGH HEAVEN.
BUT THE PROBLEM WITH
PARTISANSHIP, THERE'S SOMETHING
IN HERE THAT'S WORTH TALKING
GREATEST PERSON ALIVE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT HIM.
IT'S ABOUT THE UNVERIFIED,
UNDOCUMENTED INFORMATION FROM
ANONYMOUS SOURCES.
ON FOR IT IT DOESN'T MATTER WHO
THE STEELE IS BUT IT'S THE FACT
HE USED WAS NOT VERIFIED TO
HINDER OR INVESTIGATE AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN.
>> MARCO RUBIO IN THIS IS ALSO
VERY INTERESTING.
MARCO RUBIO, SENATOR -- WHY ARE
THEY COVERING FOR MARK WARNER?
WHAT'S GOING ON?
HOW DEEP IS THE DEEP STATE?
DOESN'T RUN THROUGH THE SENATE?
>> THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING!
>> I MEAN, IF SOMETHING DOESN'T
FIT INTO THE EQUATION OR THE
PARTISAN DOGMA, IT DOESN'T MAKE
IT DEEP STATE.
TRAIL.
BUT WHY WOULD A REPUBLICAN --
WHY WOULD A REPUBLICAN MATTER OF
THIS COMMITTEE THINK IT OKAY FOR
A DEMOCRAT TO GO MEET WITH THE
RUSSIANS WITHOUT TELLING -- OR
RUSSIAN LOBBYIST, WITHOUT
TELLING THE COMMITTEE
APPOINTMENT I THINK IT'S REALLY
WEIRD.
>> I THINK HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
WHETHER THE TEXT WAS KNOWN OR